here are the MPS who have declared the
most in outside earnings so far in this
Parliament and at the top it's not even
close nearly five million pounds in
earnings for Boris Johnson almost all of
that earned in the six short months
since he departed Downing Street
and 22 million pounds now that's the
total amount of money all 650 MPS have
declared on top of their 84 000 pounds a
year salary since the last election in
December 2019 and here are the MPS that
have bridged the most in outside income
so far in 2023 so we've got the data for
just under two months of earnings now
understandably many of these numbers are
quite small but one man clearly is
having a very good year financially at
least the former prime minister has
registered over 3.7 million pounds in
extra income just since the third of the
year he's been paid over 500 000 pounds
by publisher harpercollins for a book
that's yet to be published and nearly
two and a half million pounds from an
agency which the former prime minister
describes as an advance for speaking
engagements now the sheer scale of Boris
Johnson's earnings are really rather
extraordinary so look at this 4.4
million pounds is the total sum of
outside earnings made by all 650 MPS so
far in 2023 and of that figure Boris
Johnson alone has earned 85 percent of
the cash
the highly paid speaking gigs have
spanned Singapore New York and Mumbai
and now Westminster North Parliament
this a conference just down the road
Boris Johnson giving his first public
reaction to rishi's next brexit deal
what just happens to be a very lucrative
platform
Chris Johnson how much are they paying
you to pronounce at the brand Finance
conference why aren't you doing this in
Parliament
Uxbridge in West London is where Boris
Johnson has made his political home this
is not a safe seat some constituents far
from Happy do you think he should stand
again and if you if he did would you
vote for him
um no I don't think I'd vote for him
again
um he's making a lot of money like you
say doing other things so yeah step down
I'm okay with that but I wanted him to
focus more on his constituency but I'm
here working six days a week but I never
see him being slung out of office by his
own party doesn't appear to have dented
Boris Johnson's earning power but is
this the golden future he dreamed of